[Musica]
bella tutti ragazzi e benvenuti a questo
nuovo video sono famiglie oggi sono
troppo contento di presentarvi della
stoffa parte 2
siamo su io non solo da fare il mio
mestiere quindi va be it the lich che
significa in italiano mangia il ricco in
che senso questo è un gioco che fa
proprio per metro a tutte le persone del
mondo che io sono il più azzeccato
perché è un gioco per tirchi nel senso
che costa un euro come john ed è un
gioco incentrato sul black trade e in
che senso nel senso che tu comandi
queste persone che chiamarle persone
sembra anche un po pietro è un
complimento dunque va bene gli usi per
prendere gli oggetti in giro per
acquistare gli oggetti giro ad uno
sconto incredibile è già partito il
tempo aiuto aspetta da solo capace c'è
una salve buongiorno c'è un pelato qui
hai niente
oddio abbiamo reclutato il pelato
scoprendo il carrello salde e venga
anche lei
oh mio dio non pensavo fosse così
intelligente questo gioco ha reclutato
gente ho solo 20 salve buongiorno ho
comprati carrelli la cover
io voglio usare i carrelli non comprare
i carrelli aspetta prendi marche 9
secondi aiuto simpatico non capisco poi
compra i carrelli compre carrelli
comprali a roma sono ok quindi fare
tutto nel tempo limite o che ho capito
ciò è veramente un casino sto gioco però
che tu devi reclutare gente e man mano
comprare oggetti veramente fi e chi è il
genio che sia montato sta roba
ma per adesso avevamo il 25 per cento
però posso comprare ulteriori sconti
quindi ad ales avevo il 50 per cento
perfetto new morning coffee più 15
secondi va bene mi copro anche quelli
che sono sempre utili va bene
francis faceless gol in quattro ragazzi
reclutiamo lei reclutiamo pure lui lui
non lo reputiamo che va bene murray
comprende tutto il carrello perfetto
adesso le cose mi danno il doppio perché
ho usato il male sociale a metà dello
sconto e la matematica è difficile
ragazzi ho fatto solo i superiori non
rompete le balle
allora ci stanno ai pesci grandi pesci
cos'è c'è un televisore perché c'è una
mano animano ma che te ne fai una banana
c'è un televisore ii 25 secondi aiuto
e vabbè usato mi schianto sulla cassa
neanche mi mi ci avvicino normalmente va
bene prendi i carrelli ragazzi io non ho
idea di quanto possa costare un carrello
non ho mai mi sono mai posto il problema
ma va bene quello non abbiamo reclutato
ma il televisore l'ho preso bene 7
secondi veloci pl banane preparare
veloce madonna dai va bene va bene
onesto un voto fatto perfetto non ho
idea di che cosa siamo quelle due cose
perché non sono studiato ma va bene fa
niente savings credo sia risparmio però
non ne sono si va bene gli avanti 244
dollari posso comprarmi booster retweet
20 io con un tweet chiamo all'adunata
gente che vi aiuta
a comprare cosa a metà prezzo compriamo
l'adunata vai newsletter 120 ma copre
ombre quello ma si social media manager
siamo più 7 per ora per un dollaro mi
compro più 30 secondi di mortacci di
dollari cioè la mappa beh vabbè abbiamo
finito va bene reclutiamo pure questi a
posto
non ho capito se quelli che perché uno è
pelato non ho capito se quelli che
recluti poi ti rimangono sta cosa non
l'ho capita ma fa niente
entriamo veloci come un'orda di zombie
perfetto vendete coi barili di benzina
chissenefrega
ho bisogno ma torna alle 23 di e vai vai
vai vai ho preso tutti i potenziamenti
giusti perfetto ragazzi oggi facciamo
l'odissea dello sconto la carta igienica
dall'altro alcuni si sono messi il casco
ma non ho capito se non vogliono vendere
o cosa non capisco i barattoli veloci
che manca poco veloci 10 secondi va bene
va bene va bene a me trascinati al
traguardo sembrano delle trote
spiaggiate va bene quanto fatto già
avevo un esercito contestavo stava
comandando un esercito tutti
all'esselunga va bene non ho mai capito
ma anche 480 ho fatto perché io con lo
sconto miri vendola roba giustamente a
di one hundred per sensei wins cioè con
mille dollari prendo tutto gratis va
bene questa roba vorrei subito se
possibile grazie comunque ragazzi sto
gioco è una figata non so se è chiaro ma
è esattamente c'è la swat compro pure
quella oddio c'è una motorino a parte il
motorino c'è per un'altra stanza una
motosega ragazzi qua dovete fare piazza
pulita non avete cave sfondato il muro
comprate tutto anche le cose che non
servono quando ci sono gli sconti di
amazon io sono uguale
comunque normale che amazon ha un sito e
non devo andare fisicamente se non
sarebbe più o meno così
poi io con il fisico che ciò non potrei
sollevare televisori robot re massimo
prendere un pacco di fazzoletti prova
beh
prendete tutto per favore che siete
tanti ognuno può prendono la roche casa
radicato un cesso lì per cortesia
vabbè i televisori li avete lasciati lì
non si sa per quale motivo strano però
ok basta che vendete la roba per favore
vai 98 bene bene bene i carrelli di veto
dei carrelli benissimo avete consegnato
bene via abbiamo ancora 47 secondi
veloci pesci pesci prendi pesci la carta
qui c'è un altro cesso la veloci che le
robe non si comprano da sole mamma mia
ma vi bravi o no ma dove domandato
quello dove andare non c'è niente li
torni indietro non è delle robe
bravissimi madonna ragazzi lo svaligiato
questo la slot non ha guardato niente
gliene fregava nulla forse riesco a
prendere un paio di barattoli in più ma
niente di che con quei ragazzi ottimo è
veramente il gioco che fa per me
quest'altro in è pinguis signori molto
alto fatto va bene
1621 dollari va bene compriamo tutto
gratis più 10 persone e più 17 in totale
va bene in questo momento siamo al
massimo di quello che possiamo prendere
quindi credo più di così non si può fare
è impossibile siamo pronti per il rush
finale
o no stai comprando i prodotti gratis
questo è come rubare non credi ebbe
anche prima non è che fossero sembra
proprio un lavoro per la polizia di
stato dove i continui no come i tubi
continua come toni continua siete scemi
io mi ero preso benissimo ma come tu mi
continuano no fermi ne sono fatte fare
però non me ne frega niente se fate il 2
voglio voglio usare il 100 per cento
disco ecco celo celo celo meno male e
finito il gioco ma chi se ne frega c'è
il 100 per cento di sconto alla pesos
via veloci e quindi puoi rifarti il
gioco 200 per cento di sconto
ho capito quindi fanno anche il 2 con la
polizia non l'abbiamo socio che geniale
ragazzi degno di una trama di spielberg
attendo il secondo come se fosse la
discesa di gesù in terra praticamente il
gioco della vita questo ragazzi
vendetela aveva adesso avendo tutto c'è
proprio ismi l'altro che cosa mi serve
vendere non posso comprare niente prove
ma chi è che sta importunando la
cassiera la mio dio
comunque no veramente ragazzi e geniale
sta roba c'è il gioco più bello che
abbia mai visto nella storia perché non
me li fate scoprire subito si giochi ma
edizione sai ai tempi quanti iscritti
facevo questa roba
voglio svaligiare per una volta tutto
locale e dopo che uno svaligiato voglio
vedere nella mappa dopo che cosa c'è
verso l'infinito ragazzi che son curioso
che non dovrebbe esserci più niente
teoricamente ho venduto tutto ho fatto
1.120 ho venduto tale solo il palo posso
lo posso prendere il palo
posso vendere solo più il palo della
luce che però non lo prendono vabbè fa
niente i caschi sedimento nomi non
servono a nulla
vendola cassiera non lo so ho venduto
veramente tutto non c'è più niente
ragazzi
salve che bello avere lo sconto totale
non prendete non fai nulla veramente a
posto
benissimo questo specchio posso comprare
anche niente
va bene la diamo solo a vedere che cosa
c'è se vai in fondo anche se non penso
ci sia nulla però proviamo io ringrazio
dio che esistono questi giochi che io
veramente vado all'e3 di los angeles per
vedere i trailer dei giochi sopra delle
stesse roba del genere ormai non credo
che ci sia nulla anche perché secondo me
poi continuare all'infinito proponiamoci
non si sa mai con un pesce le scale the
walking dead season 9 c'è gente che
inciampa a caso ma perché puoi saltare
non lo sapevo
c'è un tasto per saltare saltano saltano
randomicamente però va bene ragazzi non
c'è più nulla
purtroppo non lo so come se votare così
all'infinito che peccato
qualche ansia di vivere stagione beh io
non lo so ragazzi fantastico che mettano
anche l'apple store nel secondo perché
ho speso un sacco per questo è ancora
sto cercando di qualche check in in
screen sul telefono e ancora sto
cercando di farmene una ragione per la
tirchiaggine che ciò però questo gioco
mi fa sfogare almeno quello signori però
che vi sia piaciuto questo era in the
reach che era il gioco dei mega sconti
bellissimo spero che facciano il 2 molto
intelligente non fate così perché vi
arrestano prova pecorona tris con sei
video piaciuto molto il tracciato
momento mi piace iscrivetevi spiaggia
della campanellina per essere aggiornati
sono un video che escono perché molto
importante e rai come semplici mediano
hanno proseguito bel ragazzo
[Musica]